Here are my five hacks for having a good time at the fair this fall.
Our family likes to go every year
and the biggest thing is to wear comfy clothes
so you can walk around and have a good time.
When it comes to rides, download the Fun Pass app.
You can see all of the rides that they have
and how many tickets they cost.
You can also buy tickets. Plan out your whole night.
We were able to hit so many rides in just a couple hours.
The next thing is to share food.
That way you can try a little bit of everything.
And if you go on Fridays, they have food items for $3 which was amazing.
When you need to take a little break in between the rides and the food,
be sure to check out the concerts they have going on
as well as the petting zoo.
My kids absolutely love seeing the animals.
It was so much fun. If you really want to win a stuffed animal,
try and find the games that are more off to the side
that have less people. Or
my favorite tip
is to just go with a guy who is good at shooting basketballs
and you can get a stuffed animal that way.
I think the fair is so underrated and we had such a good time.
Recommend 10 out of ten.